i'm here with simon Purkiss the founder
of pearline london these luxury chess
sets us a little bit about what it's
like to be here at the London chess
classic and your SATs sure it's a
pleasure to be here Jennifer thank you
and so we've worked with 25
british-based artists so far to create
these unique chess sets so this one is
by virginia griffith-jones who is a
landscape painter and very colorful this
one is by inky who's a very famous
street artist from Bristol the same city
where Banksy is from and they're all
completely one off I recently returned
from San Luis from the world chess Hall
of Fame where jennifer and I were lucky
enough to have some artwork on this on
display at the Museum of the world chess
or the pain and yes sir two of our
artists crystal Fischetti and daniela r
hf their two sets are exhibited there
and had a great reception it was
wonderful to be there so fantastic yeah
ladies night chats and st. Louis so it's
really fun to see a little bit of st.
Louis here at the London Trask lasek
especially because of the time with a
grand test or so you said this one was a
British Street artist right and by the
same city is banks so this could be so
this could be him right this could be
man's gear right oh it isn't but inky
inky has done collaborations with Banksy
as well sir yep they're pretty they're
pretty close mates I think fantastic so
which one of these I'm gonna take home
and you guys I want to tell over there
may be one of those so it's quite nice
ex-display and then we did it
illuminated boards as well which are
quite fun yes glow-in-the-dark task so
lots of events with those and members
clubs and bars and things so play chess
with a glass wine and beer and things so
yeah it's great thank you so I'm gonna
be taking um yeah these chess sets oh
hey